I'm a little interested in when when you
just kind of gave us the idea of why
someone should donate to Yale I was
wondering how receptive your donors are
to your message that you just gave right
now what kind of donors are you
appealing to and is it like really
wealthy businessmen or is it more like
people who have made their fortune and
like entrepreneurs or maybe at law or
something or and kind of also do they
have their own agendas when they come in
they want specific changes or do they
just want to follow the university's
lead mm-hmm that's a really interesting
question and the first part you know
what kinds of donors do we work with we
try to work with you know the whole
alumni group obviously not everybody is
you know willing to engage or so but you
know through our annual fund you know
everybody has an opportunity to give a
small gift and you know they add up they
are up significantly we have you know we
raised about 26 million dollars in
unrestricted gifts do the Annual Fund
but then we work with individuals who
have you no capacity to get fifty
thousand dollars or a hundred thousand
or a million or all the way up to you
know nine-figure gifts so we try to you
know cover everybody and even we are
working with parents meaning not parents
who themselves went to Yale but parents
whose only connection to Yale is through
their the kids who are currently here
and you know obviously those individuals
who give us you know we have parents who
gave us ten million dollars in addition
to paying tuition and all of that so we
try to work with as many donors as we
can but it's a you call you you talk
about a very intriguing issue and that
is you know does a donor come with ideas
or you know its donor just waiting for
us to tell them this is what we like you
to do well obviously you know it's it's
it's a you know it costs the board
the University always has its priorities
its vision etc and obviously when we go
out we would like to you know make a
compelling case that individuals should
you know give to that but when somebody
has the capacity and the interest of
making an extraordinary Lee large gift
you know they tend to come with their
own ideas and then it is becoming a very
interesting of interesting in a kind of
negotiation and I negotiate is not the
right word it becomes a very interesting
conversation that sometimes may take
very long to complete because of course
you know if I have a hundred million
dollars to give away I probably gave it
some thought what I want to do with it
and you know I have a dream I I want
something you know to happen and I think
yell is the best place for it to happen
so you know what is there to talk about
and we say well you know we have these
other needs over here or it would freak
and so and so forth but you know we have
to remember you know the beginning of
philanthropy the Golden Age of
philanthropy you know it was the big
donors the big gifts who made things
happen so we better take you know
seriously when people come with big
ideas and see rather than saying well if
we can't if we have to do it exactly
this way I we don't want to do it but to
think about so what is behind the idea
you know what does this person really
want to accomplish and how do I you know
what is here where this would fit and so
you kind of try in those conversations
to for both sides to move toward one
another and come to something in the end
and that's important that both parties
are really happy about so two of you do
international studies you know we have
the Jackson Institute that was funded
through a gift that was the idea of the
donor
and you know while Yale was interested
and heavily invested in
internationalisation at the time you
know we were more thinking of finding
scholarships to send students abroad you
know in the summertime or you know
getting international students here
thinks of that nature so we didn't have
the establishment of an institute on our
list but the donors made a compelling
case and it forced us it was the Yale to
think about it and you know by the time
the agreement was signed you know both
the donors as well as Yale had moved
from where they were when we started the
conversation to something where
everybody is very happy and you know i
have heard president 11 talk about the
jackson institute as the best academic
startup he has ever seen you know so it
worked